[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Thank you.
Thank you.
It's good to be here.
I've watched a couple
of these talks online
and I know that sometimes
they're very lighthearted.
This one won't be.
My life started to change
considerably in 2010
when about 10 Somali
pirates were arrested
for trying to capture
a German cargo ship
and hauled in front of a
court in Hamburg in Germany
where I was working
as a journalist.
It was the first
time pirates had
been in front of a German
judge for almost 400 years.
So it was an extremely
interesting story,
and I started to cover it
for Spiegel Online where
I was working.
A lot of the German
defense lawyers in the room
said that their
clients were just
sort of poor fishermen, which
is a story you've probably
heard plenty of times because
it's talked about sometimes
when Somali pirates come up.
This was a group of
10 young Somalis armed
with AK-47s and rocket launchers
that boarded a cargo ship
and only were kept from
hijacking it when the Dutch
Navy came in and overpowered
them with gunfire
and arrested them on the deck
and sent them to Germany.
So these men were
caught red handed.
But by the time they landed in
Hamburg, their defense lawyers
had statements prepared claiming
they were just poor fishermen
and they'd been press ganged
by real pirates and stuff
like that.
And again, that's
a common story,
and it has something to do with
the roots of Somali piracy.
But there's this tale you
hear that most pirates are
just disgruntled
fishermen trying
to make an honest living,
but they can't, and so they
go out and capture big ships.
These are complicated
issues, and they
can be a little confusing.
Since you're engineers, I'm
going to be a little bit
wonky today about them.
But I'm going to talk about
fishing and piracy and even
Islam and a few
related topics in a way
that I hope sheds light
on Somalia a little bit
and also on what happened
to me in Somalia.
So I was captured
and held hostage
by pirates in central Somalia
for over 2 and 1/2 years.
And by the time I
got out, I didn't
think I was going to see my
family and friends again.
Before I went
there, I had worked
as not just a journalist,
but also an author in Berlin,
and I had traveled quite a
bit to Europe and Africa, Cuba
and the Middle East.
I wrote a book about surfing.
Cleo mentioned that it was not
just about surfing, but also
about the spread of
American culture or pop
culture since surfing is not
just American, around the world
after World War II.
And in the Horn of Africa while
I was doing some of that work,
I met a documentary
maker named Ashwin Raman.
He's a very good journalist.
He's born in India,
but works in Germany.
And since we were both living
in Germany at the same time
and we both had an
interest in pirates,
we talked about some
traveling to Somalia together.
Ashwin had been there.
He does war documentaries
for German TV
from Afghanistan,
Iraq, and Guantanamo.
He knows how to move in and
out of dangerous places.
So when we started to
plan a trip to Somalia,
we didn't do it lightly.
We found a Somali
elder in Berlin
who had taken another journalist
from Germany to the same region
before safely.
And I took time and earned a
grant for some of my expenses
from the Pulitzer Center
on Crisis Reporting.
We planned the trip for months.
Then finally we flew to
Somalia in early 2012,
planning to stay
for about two weeks.
We stayed in Galkayo, which is a
town you may not have heard of.
It's a central Somali town where
lots of pirates happen to live.
But it's nowhere
near the coastline.
It's actually a very big city.
It's 100,000 people, which
is quite large for Somalia.
And it's big because
it's a crossroads town,
and that's one reason that some
Somali pirates have used it
as a sort of resupply
town and a place
to retreat and build
their houses, too.
From Galkayo, we
made one excursion up
to Hobyo, which is a town
you probably have heard of.
It's a pirate town on the coast.
And we had a conversation
with a pirate boss who called
himself Mustaf Mohammed Sheikh.
And he posed himself
as sort of a guy who
was at war with
European interests
somehow, with the people
who dump poison waste off
of Somali beaches, which the
Italian mafia certainly does,
and with companies
that come down
and take Somali fish, which
French and Portuguese fishing
ships have certainly
been known to do,
and also some Asian companies.
So he was full of
legitimate complaint.
But it turns out that he's
like a lot of antique pirates
in that sense.
Pirates in history have always
been a little bit rebellious,
and they've always had
some sort of complaint
to back up what they do.
But with pirates,
you have to untangle
their legitimate complaints with
their main motivation, which
is greed.
And I would argue that
when Somali pirates started
capturing big cargo ships
instead of fishing ships
off the coast, and especially
when they started capturing
people on land, that it was
no longer about defending
their coastline from
illegal fishing.
So we spent not very much time
in Hobyo, just sort of a day,
and we came back to Galkayo,
and Ashwin decided to--
there's Galkayo again--
Ashwin decided to
fly off to Mogadishu.
And so we agreed to do
everything together,
and we both went to the airport
with our security, saw him off,
Ashwin got on the plane,
and it was on the way
back from the airport that
a truck was waiting for us.
It was actually
called a technical
on the side of the road between
the airport and Galkayo proper.
A technical looks like that.
It's a flatbed truck with
a canon welded in the back,
and it's a very common sort
of improvised battlewagon
in the Somali Civil War.
This is not a picture of the
one that was waiting for us,
but the one that was waiting
had 12 guys in the back
with Kalashnikov,
something like that,
and at first we thought maybe
it was there to protect us.
But it moved when
it saw the car,
and it aimed that big cannon
through the windshield,
and it overpowered my guard.
And the 12 guys with
guns came across,
came off the flatbed and
over to my side of the car
and pulled me out.
They beat me on the head.
They beat my wrist because I was
trying to keep the door closed.
They broke my wrist.
They bloodied my scalp.
They broke my glasses, which I'd
been wearing and which I need--
I'm extremely
near-sighted-- and then
they bundled me into
an SUV that was waiting
by the side of the road, and
we drove off into the Somali
Bush, which looks like that.
And those were my
circumstances after that
for the next 2 and 1/2 years.
We found a camp
in the Somali Bush
where some other
pirates were staying,
and a couple of
hostages too, but I
was too confused to
understand what was going on.
There was a mattress
waiting for me.
I sat on the mattress.
Somebody gave me some food,
some bread and canned tuna,
and that would more or
less be my diet, at least
for the next few months--
canned tuna and bread and some
bottled water and some pasta.
And in the next two or three
months, I lost about 45 pounds.
But for a treat-- actually, this
is digression-- but no matter
what else we ran out of, no
matter what else went wrong,
even if we ran out
of bottled water,
for some reason we always
had biscuits and mango juice.
That's a sample of the
vanilla biscuit box we got.
It was a big part of my
experience in Somalia,
this brand, but in spite of
the sugar, I still lost weight.
So those first days
were very confusing.
But gradually, I got to know
the other two hostages that
were there at the camp, and one
of them I was thrown together
with for some reason.
We became partners, at least
from the pirates' point
of view.
He and his friend were both
fishermen from the Seychelles.
And this guy,
Rolly, was about 69,
kind of a squat
old man who spoke
a French-inflected
Seychellois Creole.
That's Rolly.
He and his friend Marc were
both fishing about 50 miles out
of their home port
of the Seychelles.
The main island
of the Seychelles
is about 700 miles
from the Somali coast.
And they were just cleaning
their fish at night
and the pirates came
up and took their boat
and overpowered them
with guns and said,
you have to sail
back to Somalia now.
It took them a week.
They were a week
away from Hobyo.
So that was one of
my first impressions
of life as a hostage.
The first two other
hostages I met
were two poor African fishermen
captured near their home
and hauled back to
Somalia and held
for the staggering
sum of $20 million
by pirates who pretended to be
oppressed by industrial fishing
boats.
So that was one myth exploded.
And a few days after-- so
there's both of them, actually.
That's a picture of Rolly
and a picture of Marc.
I'm happy to say they're fine.
That's on the day they
got back from Somalia
some time after I met them.
Now, a few days
after my capture,
the US launched a rescue to
get two other hostages who
were there in Somalia.
They had been captured
completely separately
and it was probably
a different gang
that was holding them, but
maybe some clan relationships
between that gang and my gang.
They'd been in Somalia
for a few months.
And for some reason, four
days after my capture,
SEALs went in and got them.
They knew exactly
where they were.
They killed nine Somali guards
and rescued the two hostages
safely.
The two hostages were Jessica
Buchanan and Poul Thisted,
an American and a
Dane, and they were
working for a demining NGO.
And they-- I mean, I've met
Jessica in the meantime--
really good people.
But the rescue upset my guards.
They upset, I think,
some of my bosses,
too, because they said
that they had some clan
relationships to the guards.
So a few days
after their rescue,
they made the original
demand for my release,
and the original
demand was $20 million.
My mom didn't know what
to do with that one.
$20 million-- they probably
didn't pull that out
of the air.
They were asking $20
million for other people,
including the two fishermen.
But they held on to it, in
my case, for almost a year.
So I think that has something
to do with the rescue.
Rolly turned out
to be a chatterbox.
And he told me a strange thing.
He said that he
had seen my picture
before the pirates brought me to
that camp sort of blindfolded.
One of the guards had a
picture of me on his phone.
And then a couple of days
before I arrived there
with the blindfold, the
guards had disappeared,
which means that it was
extremely well-planned
and they knew what
they were trying to do.
And eventually I
saw this picture--
a guard showed it
to me on his phone--
and it happens to be my author
picture from my second book.
So they did some research
on me on the internet.
That narrows down
the number of people
who could have planned it.
But it also told me something
crucial because until then I'd
been traveling as a German.
I'm also a German
citizen, and I'd only
traveled on my German
passport in Somalia.
But the pirates must
have known very well
that I was an American before
they decided to capture me.
And the reason
that's interesting
is that Americans think that
we have a hostage policy that
keeps us safe.
Everyone knows-- I
think everyone knows--
at least every journalist
knows that the US doesn't
pay ransoms, and the reason
it doesn't pay ransoms
for cases like this, for
any case of kidnapping,
is that if you start to
pay criminals to do that,
then more criminals will do it.
And so the idea is that it
will keep Americans safe.
The pirates were obviously
trying to get money
from every possible source.
They called my mother.
They called "Der
Spiegel Magazine."
They called the US government
and the German government.
They just thought that the
more places they called,
the more money was going
to fall from the sky.
It was very unrealistic,
but most of my pirates
really did think that
the US government was
going to shell out money.
They just thought, well,
it's the wealthiest
country in the world,
and so why wouldn't they?
And I know that because
one guard who held me
for a long time named Boshko--
I have a picture--
kept me updated on negotiations.
And one day, a year and
a half into my captivity,
he came into the room
very angry because someone
had told him that
there was going
to be no money coming
from Washington.
In other words,
until then, he had
believed that some
portion of my ransom
was going to be paid
by the US government.
And when some Somali
negotiators probably
told him that it
wasn't going to happen
and he had to sort of reduce
his expectations for a ransom,
he was really angry.
And he came in and he said, why?
Why won't the US pay?
It's such a wealthy country.
Why wouldn't they pay
for one of their people?
And I tried to explain
the whole thing to him.
But the rationale started
to weaken a little bit
while I was trying to explain
it to him because this was
a year and a half
into my captivity
and it was incredible to me
that my own kidnappers weren't
keeping track of these policies.
Somebody wasn't listening
to the politicians
from behind the podium who said,
we have a hard line on this
and don't even try it.
And it turns out kidnappers
like that either don't care
or they don't know the
difference between some
of these countries.
In fact, I knew Boshko
didn't know the difference
between England and France.
He wanted me to draw
a map at some point
to show him which was
which, which means
that most of these
guys' conception
of European
geography is about as
good as the average
American's conception
of African geography.
So if you can imagine
your understanding
of African hostage
policy, then maybe you
can understand why a lot of
groups in the wider world
don't keep very good track of
differences in policy, if any,
in Western countries.
So the point is that
that was a bitter way
to have a second myth
exploded as a captive.
American hostage policy does
not keep us safe in the way
that we think it does.
The pirates knew I was American,
they targeted me on purpose,
and then they held out for money
in spite of what I considered
a very famous hardline policy.
There are some implications
for that, and one of them
is not that I think
the US should shell out
money for ransoms.
But I just think it's important
for an American audience
to understand that the ideas
we have about that policy
are not always true.
I want to say a little
more about Boshko
because he claimed
not to be a pirate.
He watched me every day with
a Kalashnikov in his hands,
but he would say, on these
sort of long afternoons
where we had conversations,
broken conversations, that he
wasn't a pirate.
He was just a guard.
And it's possible that a
great big pirate gang--
there must have been hundreds
of people in the network--
is broken up into
little cells, and you
might have an attack
cell and a guard cell
and the cell that organizes
a telephone call for a ransom
discussion or the
food-- some people just
have to organize the food--
but all those little groups
have to be within
the pirate network
and they have to be
trusted by the guards.
So as far as I was concerned,
Boshko is a pirate.
And the other interesting
thing about him
is that he was a
very devout Muslim.
In fact, all my guards
prayed five times a day,
which is a bit of a surprise
to me because I thought--
I knew Somalia was
a Sufi nation, but--
predominantly
Sufi-- but I didn't
expect to see my pirates
praying quite so often,
and they were extremely
devout about it.
And it actually got me
angry to watch them do it.
And so finally, I asked Boshko--
I said, you are a Muslim.
He said, yes, because he
was very proud of that.
I said, but, Bashko,
you are also a thief.
I said, these things
don't go together.
I said, no same same.
This was our language.
And he laughed at
that because he
understood what I was saying.
And I think it
pricked his conscience
because after a couple
of weeks, he kept--
over the next two weeks, he
kept coming back to the topic.
And finally, he gave
me the justification
that I think he took seriously.
He said, Michael,
you are an infidel,
and the Quran says to
struggle with the infidel.
And we are not
al-Shabaab, so we're not
fundamentalist terrorists.
Al-Shabaab is the al-Qaeda
aligned group in Somalia.
We're not going to just shoot
you for being an infidel.
But we do think we
can take your money.
Stealing from an
infidel isn't theft.
I thought that was
a strange answer.
I've never heard that
interpretation of Islam
before much as I've
traveled around.
But I thought it was
odd for another reason,
because Sufis are
meant to be very sort
of open-minded,
mystical Muslims,
and Boshko's answer had sort
of an edge of fundamentalism
in it, taking that
word in the Quran
very literally, that
word "struggle,"
and misinterpreting it
in just the right way.
But that was the third
busted myth for me
because before I
went, I really didn't
think any Muslim-oriented
pirates were going
to consider themselves
real Muslims
as long as they were
working as pirates.
But it turns out that
centuries ago, Barbary pirates
were no different.
In the 1600s and 1700s, the
great age of Barbary pirates,
you had basically what was
a religious war going on
across the Mediterranean.
There was a sort of
low-burning jihad involved
in these ships that sailed
off from North Africa
to capture Christian
ships in the Mediterranean
and take the people
back as hostages,
and that war absolutely
went in two directions.
So in other words,
Christian ships
came down and
sacked Muslim towns
on what we now call
the Moroccan coast
and took hostages absolutely
for religious reasons.
The religious motive was
the same in both directions.
And this religious war
went on for centuries.
I knew that a little bit.
But when I was in Somalia and
I had time to think about it,
I had this feeling of
having slipped back in time.
But hostages in those days, in
the 17th and 18th centuries,
were considered sort
of lost souls, people
who had dropped out
of Christian society,
maybe turned Turk, which is
the very sort of offensive term
for converting to Islam.
But one of the people who
did this who was captured
was Miguel Cervantes.
He was held by Barbary
pirates for maybe five years.
He was a soldier and,
with his brother,
he went out to a
battle somewhere else
in the Mediterranean
against the Ottoman Empire,
and it was on the way back
that his ship, close to Spain,
was actually captured
by some Barbary pirates.
And the two Cervantes
brothers were taken and held
prisoner in the
bagnios of Algiers--
so underneath the
city of Algiers.
Cervantes tried to
escape five times.
I'm not sure where he
thought he was going to go.
People considered
hostages in those days
to be somehow
compromised because--
and it's the same now--
they're a little
bit unfortunate,
but also a little
bit morally suspect
because they've fallen into
the hands of the enemy.
They've allowed themselves
to be used as pawns
or to raise money for
evil men, which is--
that's the point of a ransom.
A criminal gang is raising
money for more criminality.
And I felt that moral
compromise very deeply.
In fact, I brooded
over it every day
and sometimes I
considered suicide.
I had the idea that
getting rid of myself
would solve a bunch of problems.
It would end the
problem at home.
I knew my mother was suffering.
It would save any SEAL team the
incredible risk of a mission
of trying to come get me.
And once in 2014, I heard--
I had a radio at that point--
and I heard "The New York
Times" journalist
Rukmini Callimachi talk
about how some
European countries
sort of paid ransoms through
back channels for some people
being held by al-Qaeda in the
Maghreb in Western Africa,
and that just made
me feel awful.
I just felt-- it inflamed
my sense of guilt.
And I know Rukmini,
in the meantime,
and I think she's
terrific and I think
she's a very
wonderful journalist,
but this was my state
of mind at the time.
And I was also angry.
I was angry at the guards.
Excuse me.
I was angry at their bosses.
I was angry at myself for
getting into that mess.
And so every day in
Somalia, especially when
I was held alone, was this
sort of maddening cauldron
of anger terrible food.
And it was another thing
I heard on the radio that
helped a little bit.
At some point later in
2014, I heard a homily
by the pope, a new
pope, Pope Francis.
I had never even heard of him.
I didn't know what
happened to the old pope.
But Pope Francis said something
about mercy, and he said,
mercy is like the
light of the sun.
At night, you see
lots of stars and you
think about your sins
and your shortcomings,
just like the stars,
and then in the morning,
the sun rises and
banishes all the stars.
And he said, the
mercy of God is like
that because it banishes
your sins with its glory.
And the idea was to, as a human,
was to pass it along somehow.
And I found that when I made a
conscious decision to do that,
to forgive people in your
life, including my guards,
including my pirates, my
self-destructive feelings
of anger and guilt
and depression,
to a certain extent,
started to lessen.
And another idea that was very
sort of hooked into that, which
I'm going to read about a
little bit from the book,
comes from stoic philosophy.
So this also had
an influence on me.
This was also sort of
going through my mind
while I was there.
I was thinking, in particular,
about the philosopher Epictetus
and some of his ideas.
Epictetus was an early stoic
and he gave lectures in Rome.
He was originally a Greek who
was crippled and originally
a slave.
And so I'll read this passage
to you from late in the book
well after I had lost hope
that I would even see my family
and friends or my home again.
I thought of them, my family,
as shades from the past.
I assumed my mother had packed
up my apartment in Berlin
and stuffed everything
into storage.
I hadn't spoken to her in 14
or 15 months on the phone.
I knew there was a chance that
this dim existence in Somalia
would end in gunfire or with
an unexpected hostage sale
to al-Shabaab, who wouldn't mind
having an American to destroy
in public.
I assumed the past was gone.
I just moved from one
moment to the next.
But Epictetus said, in more
than one of his lectures,
that real human freedom
is a moral choice.
It's the skill to
choose good over bad
and not to be distracted
by impressions.
This turned out to
be a lot of work.
By impressions, he meant
not just prejudice or reflex
or the first
impressions that we all
form about strangers, who
might be enemies of friends,
the sort of usual bending of the
light through a cognitive prism
that modern psychologists also
teach their clients to see,
but by impressions he also
meant the basic wrong impression
that good and bad can
be discovered out there
in the world among hordes of
uncontrollable other people.
Sectarian strife, dissension,
blame and accusation,
ranting and raving--
they are all mere opinion, the
opinion that good and bad lie
outside, Epictetus said.
Let someone transfer
these opinions
to the workings for the will and
I guarantee his peace of mind,
no matter what his outward
circumstances are like.
That's what I did.
I quit worrying about whether
the guards were good or bad.
I turned that critical
power on myself
and I made a conscious
decision to forgive them,
and I quit feeling so
angry and suicidal.
And I firmly believe
that that decision
is one reason I'm still alive.
Without it, I
probably would have
killed someone, which would
have been suicidal in itself.
And I believe that this sort
of inner moral decision,
a decision whether
to forgive or not
or whatever, is the only
real freedom we have,
no matter where we live, in
a mansion or on the street
or in a prison, wherever.
So in the end, it took 2
and 1/2 years for my family
and a dedicated
team of negotiators
to get me out of Somalia.
Ransom was $1.6 million.
And on the last day,
the pirates delivered me
to the Galkayo
airport where I had
seen Ashwin fly away
without even telling
me what was going on at first.
And they put me in a car and
handed me to another car,
and then finally I
drove up and there
was a plane waiting for me,
a Cessna, a small bush plane,
piloted by a wonderful British
Kenyan named Derek who I know,
in the meantime.
He's a wonderful guy.
He flew me to Mogadishu.
And at the Mogadishu airport,
an American transport plane,
C-130, landed and flew
me off to Nairobi.
The ransom was raised by my
mother from family and friends
and some magazines
I had worked for,
some institutions in
the US and in Germany.
And it was agonizing
for my family.
A few days later,
several pirate bosses
had a shootout over that money.
They had a disagreement about
who was supposed to get what
and five top bosses killed
each other, which made
the FBI's job a little easier.
And one Somali
told me afterwards
that it was a kind
of a shame that I
had been held for so long,
but the expense of holding me
for so long and then
that shootout afterwards
helped destroy the gang.
I hope that's true.
Some pirate gangs
are still working
in other branches of
business over in Somalia
even if it's not kidnapping
or hijacking ships.
But I still feel
terribly humbled.
I'm humbled by the horror of
the kidnapping and the horror
that it imposed on other
people, especially my family,
and also by the
astonishing help that I
received from a lot of people.
I can't forget it.
And along with some of these
myths that the kidnapping
managed to vaporize
for myself, there's
one other very important
and personal myth
that I think most of us walk
around with all the time,
and that is--
I mean, I can't speak for you,
but when I went to Somalia,
I had this idea that I knew
a thing or two about love,
that I somehow knew enough
to love enough to get
through an average day.
But after my kidnapping,
my mind sort of flipped
through all the people
that I used to know
and the pages of
my memory for days.
It was a little bit like
that cliche of your life
flipping before your
eyes before you get
killed, except I wasn't killed.
I just thought I was
going to get killed
and I had days and
weeks to think about it.
And I remembered
the people that I
loved with a profound sense of
having failed to love enough.
And so if I can leave
you with one impression,
that would be it.
I have this strong suspicion
that we don't love our families
enough from day to day.
And that may be one of
the most popular myths.
So if death gives
you a few moments
to think about it
before you kick off,
I'm thinking that might
be one of your thoughts,
that you fell short
or that you lived
into this illusory
cloak of anger and guilt
and self-recrimination and
blame, which are all intimately
related, and that you should
try to do a little more each day
to escape that
sort of evil cloak
and learn to love a little more
before your time comes around.
I told you it
wouldn't be cheery.
But I can take questions.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering,
it seems like if you were there
for a long time, was
boredom a real problem,
or what did you
do to kind of keep
occupied other than thinking
about the stoic philosophers?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Yeah.
Boredom was an
incredible problem.
I didn't know what to
do most of the time.
You just had to sit still.
I did-- sometimes I
had pen and paper.
So that helped.
So I could do a little writing.
Sometimes I just wrote in my
head and memorized things,
and I would come
up with long things
to memorize that I would
go through every morning--
so a kind of mental
routine in the morning.
That helped too.
And also, doing yoga helped.
When I could, I did
yoga when I was being
held in prison houses on land.
I actually asked the
pirates for a mat
and I could do about
an hour of that a day.
But that was only one hour.
So boredom was an
incredible problem.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much for
sharing your story.
I'm sure it's not something
that's easy for you to do.
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: One of
my favorite authors
is Viktor Frankl who wrote
"Man's Search for Meaning."
He wrote how hope got him
through the Holocaust.
So I'm wondering if you have
any perspective on channeling
into hope and faith.
And also, how did you
reintegrate back into the world
and seeing people
with smartphones
and lollygagging around
doing everyday things?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Yeah.
That's a good question.
I like Frankl, but
it's been a while
since I've read "Man's
Search for Meaning."
My relationship to hope
was it was complicated.
I did not maintain hope.
That was not the idea at all.
And, in fact, it
wasn't until I learned
to detach myself from hoping
at all that I found a way
to survive.
And actually, that's a
very important point.
Hope has an underside.
And if you keep going
through that cycle
from hope to despair,
which the pirates were
happy to keep me doing because
they just kept telling me, oh,
you're going to get out
in two weeks or a month
or whatever, it can be very
destructive, because every time
you go through the cycle,
you just feel worse.
And I realized that if I didn't
somehow take care of that,
it was going to get bad.
So I learned to not hope.
I learned to avoid hoping and
live without looking forward
to the future.
And that was very instructive
because you can live like that.
Americans don't like to
think so, but you can.
And it was another
reason I'm still alive.
What was the other
part of the question?
AUDIENCE: My other question
was about integrating back
into the world.
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Yeah.
Integrating back
was difficult, but--
so I got out and I
wasn't used to dealing
with people who liked me.
I was so used to
dealing with, whenever
I talked to someone
during the day,
dealing with having to
second guess what they meant
and wondering if I was
being lied to and just
saying something very simple
and brutal and that being it.
The complicated way that we
interact in our own languages
is something that I had--
that part of my
brain had atrophied.
So all the sort of
cues that people
get when they talk
around a subject
or just all the nonverbal ways
that we communicate really
overwhelmed me when
I first got out.
So I could only be in the
room with a few people.
But when I got out, I went to
Berlin and some of my family
had sort of congregated there.
And we talked about what
they had done last week.
We talked about really
ordinary things.
And having a small room full of
people doing that every day--
when we had breakfast, for
example, at the hotel--
was a strain on
me, but it helped.
And then after a while,
I could have a party
and see all my friends,
and slowly I got better.
But it did take
about a year for me
to get back to full physical
and mental strength.
And I don't take the mental
strength for granted at all.
One psychologist
actually said to me
that he wasn't going to diagnose
me with PTSD, although I had
some symptoms, but
he said, we don't
like to put an extra
pathology to recover from.
So in other words, if
you think you have PTSD,
that might be another
condition to recover from.
And in my case, that
was the right approach.
AUDIENCE: You have
a lot of strength.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for speaking.
I was just wondering,
the way that you learned
to mentally and emotionally
survive in Somalia,
do you still try to
apply that today?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Oh yeah.
Yeah, of course.
Sometimes I have to remember.
But yes, I don't think too
hard about the future anymore.
I mean, of course, I plan.
But you don't live for the
following week or the following
year.
And I don't need to.
And you have to learn to--
I can't get through
my average week
without learning to
slow down and forgive
people, all that kind of thing.
And it's a question
of gratitude,
and when I forget
that I should be
grateful about just being alive,
I find ways to remind myself.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
That was definitely
a captivating story.
Thank you.
I wanted to ask, because
I've been hearing words
like "hope" and "faith" and it's
getting me to think about some
of the Christian virtues--
and it seems like through
your profound suffering
and that experience,
you came to a very deep,
probably an extraordinarily
deep understanding of themes
like freedom and
forgiveness and love.
So are you thankful for
that experience itself
beyond just escaping that, but
just having gone through that?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Yeah.
That's a tough question.
Not yet.
I might have to work
on that a little bit.
But yes, I'm grateful
for coming out
of it and for coming out
of it with a few things
to think about.
That-- yeah.
Hope is tricky.
I try-- you can't
have this experience
and then pretend that it
doesn't belong to you.
You have to go back and forth
even if it seems like a dream
now, which it does sometimes.
So you have to let it
be there and you have
to take from it what you can.
AUDIENCE: Why do you
suppose the US decided
to save the other two
hostages but not you?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE:
Probably just circumstances.
I think when they plan
something like that,
everything has to line up,
including the intelligence.
You don't want operators going
in there if the intelligence is
wrong or somehow shaky.
An abundance of
caution, probably.
I suspect there
were plans to get me
and it was just a question
of the stars didn't align.
I'd rather be a hostage
under a cautious president
than a reckless one.
But while I was there, I was
like, someone just come get me,
you know?
AUDIENCE: I find that you tapped
into the ability of forgiveness
to be one of the main
healing and motivating
factors for survival.
And I guess my question
is, how did you keep, even
with that in mind, from
being like Cervantes
and trying to escape five times?
I think if I was in that
situation, a month or two in,
it wouldn't be
suicide, it would be
like, I'm going to take as many
of these guys with me as I can,
right?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Oh yeah.
No, that was the temptation.
And that was the idea
that I had more than once,
especially-- so there
were several phases.
I was held in the
Bush with Rolly
and then I was held on a
ship a lot like that one.
We could see that ship from
where we were anchored.
This was just on the
beach near Hobyo.
And we were on a very
similar model of tuna vessel.
The ship was-- there were
plenty of other hostages there,
so I wasn't thinking about--
to keep me company.
So I had people to talk
to besides pirates.
After the ship-- so first
of all, I did try to escape.
I jumped off the ship.
That's a totally
different story.
But it's in the book.
And after that, I
was taken on onshore
and I was being held alone
in these prison houses.
And that's when I had
those temptations.
That's when I wanted
to grab a Kalashnikov
and start shooting the guards
or shoot myself or whatever.
It came up slowly.
I mean-- but at
some point, I had
to wrestle with those feelings.
And of course, even after
I forgave them in my mind
and reoriented my head, I
thought about how to escape,
how I can get out, whatever.
I heard one story about a
French guy in Mali, I think,
who was being held by
Islamists who did get out.
And for a while, he was my hero.
I heard a report on the BBS.
And I'm like, I want
to be like that guy.
But he found a way to lock one
of his guards in the bathroom
while he prayed, separated
him from his gun.
And I'm like, well,
OK, first of all,
he had a guard who
prayed in the bathroom,
the bathroom was lockable,
he left the gun outside,
all these things, and
then he could get keys
to get out of the compound.
I didn't have any of those.
And then, he had a fairly
friendly population
when he got outside.
I couldn't quite-- but
I had plans, believe me.
And the question
was, from day to day,
whether it's worth it to try.
So some of the plans were
violent, some of them
weren't, and you don't know.
AUDIENCE: Can I
ask your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so
much for being here
and sharing your story.
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE:
Thank you for coming.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, for sure.
I guess I wanted to
ask, how long did it
take you to decide
to write the book
and whether you just struggled--
I mean, you're a
reporter by trade
and I'm sure you at least were
thinking about, if I got out,
I might write a book and tell
people about this experience--
but did you struggle at all
with whether you wanted to do it
or not?
And then kind of what does
life look like for you
now in terms of your
writing and what
you're doing professionally?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: So I'm a
writer and an author primarily.
I certainly was
thinking about a book
while I was there because
I had gone there to write
one kind of book,
and all of a sudden,
I realized I was going
to be writing a hostage
memoir, if I got out.
But after a while,
I stopped thinking
I was going to get out.
I just-- it was no
longer part of the plan.
And the first
couple of times when
I had my hands on
some notebooks,
I obviously tried to take
notes so I could have
something for when I got out.
But those notes
were taken twice.
And then I went for a
long time with nothing,
and then when I got
paper and pen again,
I started to write not
about what was going on.
So if something really
important happened,
I might make a note in German.
But the guards would look
at what I was writing,
I think because sometimes I
wrote incriminating things
in the previous notebooks
and I got them punished.
So they would sort of scan my
English for their own names
and place names and
things like that.
So I made sure to draft a novel.
And after a while,
they're like, is this
the made-up story
about the fish?
I'm like, yeah.
They're like, what
are you doing?
They didn't understand
that at all.
So I left with notebooks that
included the draft of a novel.
My worry when I got
out was whether I
had remembered enough, not
having taken assiduous notes
every day, for a book.
And I'm happy to say I did.
I didn't get down to writing it
for the first couple of months.
But once I did, I was happy
to see that it was flowing
and that I had to boil
down what I remembered.
That's it.
I mean, I don't
think I doubted I
was going to write a
book once I was free.
But it took a long time.
I mean, I'm glad I
had a publisher who
gave me the time to do it
and make it a decent book.
Now I'm working on that novel.
And I'm also working on--
I also work on the board
of Hostage US, which
is a very good nonprofit
that helps hostage
families behind the scenes just
to deal with what they're going
through, because
when I got out, I
noticed that talking
to other hostages
was far more effective
for me than talking even
to a psychologist.
Someone who's been
through that is
very helpful to other people,
and that goes for the families
too, and Hostage US tries
to put those people together
and create networks like that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So some of my
question was actually
what you just asked about what
you were going to work on next
and how this
experience would change
what you would
want to write about
or what kind of journalism
you'd want to do going forward,
especially because the things
that you've said about suicide,
for example, and depression
and finding a path
to loving yourself so that
you could forgive people
sounds a lot more
spiritual than maybe
some of your prior work
on the history of surfing.
And so I guess I'm
wondering if that's going
to compel you after your novel.
You might branch
into that direction.
And I guess I'm also kind
of secondarily wondering
if you think you're
ever, ever, ever
going to go back to Somalia.
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: The
second answer is easy-- no.
I mean, it would
really have to change,
security wise,
for me to go back.
But I think it's not that
different from what you think.
Those themes are obviously
important to me now,
the spiritual dimension
and the notion
of depression and survival.
Those themes are very important.
But all my books up
till now, on some level,
including the book
about surfing,
have been about freedom.
And so from that point of view,
I'm still mining the same vein.
But that's an abstract idea and
I can take it in any direction.
And that was true about my first
book, too, which was a novel.
And it actually had some
spiritual ideas too.
This experience
obviously sharpened
some of those ideas of what
human freedom actually means.
But that's why I read you
the quote about Epictetus
is that that was
his central theme.
In fact, I think that
quote is probably
from a book called
"On Human Freedom."
Those are big
questions, and they're
going to be interesting to
me for the rest of my life.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious.
You're talking about
the relationship
you had with the guard and
then the other people there.
So when you were leaving, what
were your parting words to them
and them to you?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE: Yeah.
It was weird because
on the last day,
they had to convince me
that I was going free.
I had gotten so used
to not hoping and not
believing the things they were
telling me that when they said
there's a car here,
you're going to go out,
we're going to take you to
the airport, don't believe it.
You can tell me whatever.
And then they said,
well, pack your things.
You're going to go.
OK.
I guess I'll pack
whatever little things I
had into this bag.
But then they shook my hand.
OK.
I guess I'll shake your hand.
They smiled and everything.
I'm like, yeah, no--
whatever.
I started to believe
then that I was probably
going to get shifted somewhere,
probably to another gang,
and that was it.
I mean, they did attempt
a formal goodbye,
but it was this weird
sort of tense situation
where I wasn't sure whether
to believe them or not.
AUDIENCE: What happened to
your fellow captors, the two
fishermen?
MICHAEL SCOTT MOORE:
The two fishermen?
AUDIENCE: How did they escape?
MICHAEL SCOTT
MOORE: So those guys
got out after a full
year in Somalia,
also I think with a ransom.
They wound up in the
Seychelles by November of 2012.
So I knew Rolly for
about eight months there
at the beginning of 2012.
And then after I left the
ship, he also left the ship,
and they put him back together
with Marc, and they flew away.
My pilot, Derek, by the
way, also flew them out,
and he told me that within
the first few minutes
of our flight out of Galkayo.
I couldn't believe it.
Somebody knew friends of mine.
SPEAKER: I think
that's going to be it.
Let's give him another
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]